this video is brought to you by keeps
hey wisecrack michael here obvious today
we're here to unpack the film with the
absolute grossest sound design the
platform this sleeper hit which
premiered in 2019 and came to Netflix in
2020 intrigued a lot of people as they
slipped into their own personal social
in distance tell the film seems made for
wisecrack a simple gross premise as
political allegory is basically as
irresistible to us as an all-you-can-eat
taco buffet but I wouldn't be here if
there wasn't something bothering me
about this film specifically is it as
smart as it thinks it is let's find out
in this wisecrack edition on the
platform is it deep or done in spoilers
ahead but before we continue I'm gonna
give a shout out to this week's sponsor
it keeps I've loved wearing hats they're
pretty much part of my identity you
probably feel the same way about your
hair it's something people recognize and
it's probably one way you express
yourself if you've ever been scared of
losing it and keeps can put your mind at
ease keeps is an affordable hair loss
treatment program that provides
fda-approved prescription and
over-the-counter medication with keeps
there's no trip to the doctor or awkward
pharmacy pickup involved you can do
everything right from the comfort of
your own home you meet with a doctor
virtually and can get the medication
delivered right to your door keeping
your hair is all about prevention so the
sooner you take actions the more hair
you can save which keeps some men even
rapport hair regrowth find out i keeps
has more 5-star reviews than any of its
competitors and why nearly 100 thousand
men trust each for their hair loss
prevention medication by clicking the
link in the description or by going to
keeps calm / wisecrack if user link you
can get 50% off your first order stop
stressing and keep your hair now back to
the show the platform follows the young
idealist Gaurang in a vertical
self-management center which is
bureaucratic speak for a food themed
purge prison inside the concrete walls
anything goes well almost anything
my stylist forgiving easy circular canal
go nothing that I do data from $30 haha
I still a little prisoners are free to
be as gluttonous as possible on their
fellow inmates murder them eat them or
do none of the above and just chill out
with a good book while all of this is
happening prisoners are served food once
a day through a floating dumbwaiter
containing elegant even decadent dishes
as the dumbwaiter makes its way through
each of the levels of the very tall
prison the tasty feast is quickly
consumed and defiled by the prisoners
closest to the top until nothing is left
for the prisoners below the basic
message of the film doesn't need a
wisecrack breakdown to decode it the
prison allegedly makes enough food to
feed everyone but the greed of those at
the top condemns those at the bottom to
die from starvation get it it's
capitalism now if the film were just
this and get a big old dumb from us
believe it or not pay Nicolas Cage to
look into a camera and whisper the only
thing you have to lose as your chains is
not enough for a wisecrack deep
certification nor does having a guy that
kind of looks like Jesus at times or a
333 story building with two prisoners
per floor which means there are 666
people but there is more to this film
than that right we're going to focus on
a couple of things here the symbolism
the use of Don Quixote and last but not
least the oh so confusing ending so
let's start with the symbolism as
director gal'd our guest a lugar Atia
has stated the film is not a social
critique but a social self-criticism in
other words it doesn't just take shots
at those in power but regular old folks
like us the viewer Goran the idealist
and trim Agassi the cynic represent two
sides of our consciousness light trim
Agassi we are self-concerned realist but
like Goran we like to pretend were above
such selfishness this seems to relate to
the basic idea that in a
hyper-competitive society we all run the
risk of acting like cannibalistic
monsters as gosta Lou or Atia argues
perhaps there are individuals who would
give up their position voluntarily to
achieve a more
arian society however for the group that
should give in that's very difficult to
collectively agree on we are all selfish
but there are some among us who are very
selfish the latter the most selfish like
the fuse and the fire of selfishness
spreads easily among the others
now we could sit here and decode little
details for example the woman who sent
Goran to the prison has no idea what the
prison is like an allegory for how those
who manage society have no idea about
the basic conditions they're condemning
others to face or how the delicate
artful presentation of the food is meant
to represent our obsession with all the
luxury capitalism produces while what's
left for the vast majority of the
world's population is abject poverty but
we're not the first to even mention this
so let's move on to the good books and
specifically Goren's a new favorite book
Don Quixote with the help of arguably
the world's first modern novel we can
better understand this symbolism and a
whole lot more
göran like all prisoners in the film
gets to bring one item but rather than
bringing a gun or a crate of vitamins
like a smart person he brings miguel de
cervantes the ingenious gentleman Don
Quixote of La Mancha
now most people recall Don Quixote as
the story of a delusional man who gets
into fights with windmills thinking
they're giants and Wow that is important
some of the basic overarching themes of
the novel can actually help us
understand what the film is trying to
say Alonso Quijano
alias Don Quixote is an elderly Spanish
nobleman who read so many books that his
brain begins to rot specifically he
reads tales of chivalry he becomes
obsessed with a nobler lost past and
ventures out on a delusional journey as
a knight errant he sets out to rescue a
Rando peasant who he deems a damsel in
distress and randomly names her Dulcinea
because why not
he also fights windmills thinking
they're Giants and declares his squire
Sancho Panza governor of some Island now
one clear parallel to these delusional
journeys is mihari a woman who once a
month kills her cellmate and goes on a
quest Mahara isn't in search of chivalry
but a child who were told doesn't
actually exist except that child is real
allegedly but I digress in the film it's
unclear what the hell is going on in
society that leads gran to voluntarily
send himself to prison to earn a degree
but that's it
exactly what happens and he hopes to
quit smoking and to read Don Quixote
along the way we don't know a whole lot
about Grenn's literary habits otherwise
but he starts off his journey like Don
Quixote has an idealist but rather than
chasing delusional visions of fighting
monsters and saving damsels in distress
he's motivated by the delusion that
basic human goodness and decency can
prevail in a trash castle like the whole
but as the film progresses he's slowly
stripped of these illusions after trying
to get others to cooperate by eating
reasonable portions he's promptly
accused of being a communist and watches
his cellmate piss on the prisoners below
them like Don Quixote Garen also loses
his mind in a more literal sense visa
vie trippy hallucinations but instead of
ideas of chivalry he's haunted by
reminders of the horrible things he's
done and witnessed in the prison after
Co murdering and eating his first
cellmate Goran scores a spot on a higher
level of the prison here he returns to
his former ideas of nobleness and human
decency this time though he does so with
the awareness that spontaneous
solidarity as his new cellmate describes
is a sham there are what it was that
anything where that doesn't that I
didn't know so he that he that done the
only way to make his fellow prisoners
more generous to those below them is to
literally threaten them with what this
exactamente location la Senora Maria had
and were stuck on me that alone was he
asked after going back down eating
another roommate but this time with no
murder and once again landing a spot on
a higher floor Garen enters a second
kind of quixotic journey he meets his
own Sancho Panza baharat and they decide
to go on a quest to the bottom of the
prison their mission is first to feed
everyone but then they get another idea
in their head to deliver a message to
the administration were not the animals
you think we are by violently enforcing
a portion control and preserving a
single panna cotta dish they will prove
the nobility of their spirit to the
people in charge of the prison la panna
cotta
el mensaje of course the sense of
nobility much like Don Quixote's is
quickly undercut as a montage of skull
bashing ensues so pretty deep but that
gets us to the end which is kind of a
giant WTF but a brief note on Don
Quixote will help us understand this
puzzling finale which kicks off when
Goran and baharat find me ruse wasn't
supposed to exist child at the bottom of
the prison after some hesitancy they
decide to feed her their prized dessert
which is to say all their skull bashing
was maybe for nothing Goran and Baja
rats obsessive mantra that the panna
cotta is the message changes Goran wakes
up from a dream realizing the girl is
the message and he descends with her to
the dark depths of the prison the ghost
of Tamagotchi paraphrases a donkey owed
a passage in which the goofy knight
remarks to Sancho about how intertwined
their fates are UNAMI Smashwords a Goran
sends her back up to the top of the
platform while walking into the shadows
to trim Agassi he is presumably very
much dead but on the bright side he has
quit smoking here's what matters and Don
Quixote the protagonist eventually gives
up his delusion renouncing chivalry and
dying in a fevered state one way to read
the finale is this Goran has also given
up his delusions of nobility or more
specifically that he can prove his
humanity to the administration by
sending them back their treasure panna
cotta instead he opts for another
message it's you who are the real
monsters and here's the proof a child
whom those in charge claimed would never
be confined in their hellhole the
takeaway of the film seems to be this
oftentimes a press folks try to prove
their own humanity to their oppressors
however perhaps their strategy should
actually need to prove the inhumanity of
their oppressors and it's a nice thought
thought-provoking defin so is the film
deep or dumb on the literary symbolism
it's pretty deep the filmmaker uses the
themes of Don Quixote in a novel and
thoughtful way but and I'm sorry I can't
stop from thinking that lots about this
movie is kind of dumb with apologies to
the director
chatty with the wisecrack crew there was
a general sense that this movie was too
on the
which is to say a little bit too
precisely resembling something I could
probably read on Twitter for most of the
film the messages if we could all stop
being greedy
there'd be enough food for everyone it's
not that I disagree with the message but
it's hardly a revelation if I can give a
more of theoretical framework on the
nosiness is to social commentary
what fan services to franchise movies
moments characters and dialogue that are
meant to have us not along and say ah
yes this speaks to me in Star Wars at
scene a recycled Han Solo lines spark a
sense of nostalgia without any of the
narrative way to the original more
broadly in media it's when old ideas are
recycled to spark a sense of agreement
without any of the provocation that idea
once originally had I'm sure the first
person who said sharing is caring was
really smart but your kindergarten
teacher is no Dostoevsky for saying so
it's not that this makes those ideas
inherently good or bad but good art
furthers the conversation instead of
putting it on a loop consider a film
like snowpiercer which also takes a
horrible stratified society as a gift
but rather than the lower classes
overthrowing their cruel overlords and
cheering bong joon-ho makes us ask
really hard questions like does the
system secretly want review designed to
make suffering inevitable it also shows
us the logic of those in power Tilda
Swinton's character is certifiably
bonkers but seems to be a real believer
with her own fears and the conductor
that keeps the nightmare chugging along
has his own very logical reasons for
being a monster he truly thinks it's the
only way for Humanity to survive and to
the platforms credit I do think the
ending kind of gets to this but if the
message really is show the people in
power what monsters they are it's hard
to do since they barely have any screen
time does it work are they swayed it's
obviously meant to be ambiguous and
revealing the answer would have been
totally weird given the prior absence
but as far as the basic idea if 2020 has
taught me anything it's that oftentimes
reality doesn't dictate political
discourse
so my final assessment there are
certainly some smarts to this movie but
it's no masterpiece
but it tried and for that to cast crew
and director deserve all the Panna
cottas their hearts desire and I'm
legitimately excited to see what Goldar
guest a lugar Atia plans on doing next
what do you think
to crotchety that's not everybody is
bong joon-ho or Nicolas Cage at this
point let us know what you think in the
comments a huge thanks to our amazing
patrons for supporting the channel hit
that subscribe button like it's an
unruly cannibalistic cell mate and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]